this capsule we will see the Algeria of
learning necessarily active parents
cloning so now we're ready to
also considered commented what one
can do active learning in the
body of learning by differences
temporal so in active learning
in fact we are our agent to himself
policy that updates so he can
make his own decisions on
that she should be
the action that takes 1 and you gave and
and usefully this tale what we want
to do is to take the action that
maximizes the expectation of the sum of
future rewards and who this formula 1
here now the problem in
learning of deaths that we estimate
only the value of a policy but
we are not going to destine ourselves
the transition distribution so the
given transition model you gave
your fencing if I'm an action learns
take an active approach
we could parallel to take a
transition model how
learning by pda
but in fact it will go a little against the
objective learning by differences
temporal that of not precisely
learn this model but learn
rather directly associated values
to states so if that's who
learning will try to solve as
problem so comment on what is avoided
learning a model of
transition and the idea is actually going
to introduce and learn
rather an action function values ​​than
s to q 2 r yes and 2 so rather than
to learn v2 is what hopes it years
the sum of the reinforcements from a
state's until the end for politics
optimal we will learn a function that
of s1 which is also the hope of the
sum of reinforcements from a
state s
but in the specific case we run
the action to the state and that continues
then
until the end by following the policy
optimal so that's what it corresponds to
the definition of our action function
barras is actually the yoyo link between the
function that in the usa and life function
it's just that the value of s
for the optimal plan
it's just the match so the value
maximum of my function where I
maximizes relative to the action so
indeed, it is hope
the sum of the reinforcements from
if I perform the action at it's
the best I can do for the
optimal policy is to take the
best action so its value to
sausage with the maximum value for
my function
q is this with respect to in the plane of
the agent if I have my job that
seals here estimated simply so of
take the action that maximizes my
function which therefore has my policy that
I can follow at this moment it is
the hac max of mac function that by
report to so I may have needed for
get an action executed when
learning to esteemed my model of
transition and expresses his luck and to
m6 of this approach where we go
use in the near by tulasne
so to get and learning
well we'll see how do we
can write recurrently the
definition of q2 is will be alas I
reminder is the sum of the rewards
future hoped from there you have to
from state it if i execute
i'm running action a and so it's okay
to recurrently correspond to the
reward was you going to have more my factor
the second time the future reward
hope they just so quickly the
the hope of actually my value to
policy-weighted mind state
I arrive at the premium ethos from s
if I execute the action to which my argument
is now empty es premium
Well, it's actually equivalent to
maximum compared to the action that I
will be able to execute a spirit even of my
function
q2 is this bonus after so I managed to
recurrently write the value of
q2 s up compared to all my others
qi values ​​of his so had two
minds
and as in the projecting of what we
will do is we will use that for
deduce a way to update my
function my estimate my function qds
I take my job one hour
current is frozen incremented by a
learning rate times the difference
between the information I gained due
to the fact that I went from state s to
the state expresses by executing an action to
give - my present value my
current estimate of q2 is ok and so
actually because I have this
relationship here in q2 and the others that
minds my premium if I observe that
it's possible to go from s to a
mind state give me but I could
try to get closer to the
reward rds more gamma times my
a current estimate of which
would be the awards photo is
hoped from express so emptied this
premium then that's equivalent or at
maximum barbara prime of q is this
crime says so we see the similarity
with the rule td we have here from
temporal differences
so I look like my most haf x range
folks but the generic successful
according to my function that I
know of esteemed and here instead of videos
is this qds player to then this is the place
to have said this vehicle is
thing here
and so that's going to be the rule
the learning that we will use in
learning that offered them a
example still actually our
environment and three states so at
early feeder read my table of
so my function than zero so for s 0
the action at 1 to 0 but same thing for l0
the action at 2.26 at 0 saad also
same thing for is simple for s2 seen
that it's a terminal state I'm going
specific
the action it's going to be always the same
action the man action then i'm going to me
serve to 0 range
I will use like everything
learning point 5 then a rate
of 5 0 points 5 also just for
what this example if not these debates
their loans specified there is no reason
particular to use these values
there here then at the very beginning so we
start the simulation
I arrive at the start state s 0 general
we think of them - 10.1 and when if
in fact we do nothing we want everything
just remember that we've been to
start you got 0 then we got the reward
at 2 - 0 point 1 and so we can not
update because we have
need to choose what is the action
that I'm going to take the state is what I
can choose when so if the first
thing I'm going to do I'm going to choose
what actions I'm going to perform in
s 0 and the idea if here to take a max
from q2 0 to 1 or q 2 0 to 2 when if i have
used both to zero so
arbitrarily I will choose 2
I could have chosen 1
because if I decided to choose the
radio I take the action to two lots
I observe that it brings me to the state is
zero and when I'm going to do that is
I will update my function
to go you have 0 and assuming that I took
the action at 2 according to the formula of
day 2 of the nerve nor so I will do my
old value and I have a crime between
the learning rate 0.5 point
information based on the fact that I
makes a transition from s 0 to 0 - my
current estimate of the function
my previous state s 0 and the fact that
I took action at everything so I'm going
just replaced so kind here r20 which
is less 0 point when I was in 06
I got the reward month 0.1 plus my
discount rate times the maximum between
the two values ​​of the function qu to a1
and a2 game the initialized to zero so
it's the max of 0 0 so if I do everything
this calculation to I get a value for q
2 0 to 2 2 - 0 points 0 5
to know if I have to take an action
in my new state which is in is
still 0 because I made a
transition from 10 is reopened to 0 and there
I have to choose then to action I have to
take it so I'm still going to arms
axis between q 2 0 to a shield 2 0 to 2 but
now that from 0 to 2 is equal to
less than 0.05 so in that if in
done I'm going to have a change in the
politics I will rather choose
action at one year the state and unfolding
before I had chosen the action on May 2
of love action suppose that in my
simulation it can not pass 2 0 as 1
so now I can make a bet to
day of my value of my job that
go 2-0 and the action has one that is
the previous action that I took that
I have just taken one more time
I will update it in writing
liar by alpha times information
related to the fact that I went from s 0 as
one is my present value so here here I
have to compare these quadras of my function
that in insurge by action to 2 where
the action to three I take maximum because
only if both are zero so that's fine
give 0 anyway so my new
0 culoz station to a headband if I
do the math - 0.05 household to state
is healthy I have to make a decision I
do the haf match between q drawing smells
and qds 1 to 3 so it's in 2003 because
that is trying out possible actions
according to my environment it is the action
to two where the action to you both have
been initialized to zero so
arbitrarily here I choose to two
with the action to two it brings me to pass
in my simulation as 0 and so their
household can update my values ​​of
the function that in s1 for the action to
two with the same formula as before so
I use the fact that I observed a
reverse s voltage 0 so here I
will compare that value here with
my current estimate because if
in the East
two causes for qds 0 to 1 I had less
0.05 that 2 0 it must be not them here
so I also had less 0.05 so
for both actions actually my value
of q & a f zero is equivalent to the hand
and I do the math all that gives me
a new charge value to 2 2 -
0 point 0 6 2 5
now I am happy 0 to take
an action of which it is still a
time as you are around but
value of 40 times I succeed them it goes
to be two so my value in 0 has
function that for action and action to
2 c - 0.05 so arbitrarily I
to choose one will do us business
a new transition from sg reopened
s16 that I observe in the simulation
having chosen the action at 1 previously
it allows me to update
my function that in s 0 for the action to
1.6 here I'm going to do an associated calculation
at a pull 2 ​​0 loses s1 and I compare
the body and I will take action two
breast or three stops they are according to
what I estimated by my function that
whereas if I max in 10 0 and -
0 point 1 0625 if I do all the calculation
it gives me new value for 2
011 2 - 0 points 0.75
that leads me now to take a
decision at s1
I do the max between q2 is a pure
two-man action and three-man action
that's it so the airmac feel a
negative value and 0 which brings me to
choose the action at 3 so I have a
political change
when I was at a reverse spell I had
chose the two meta action I'm going
take action at 3 and now
suppose that in the stimulation
I observe that at 3 May nice 2 we get
recalls that for the terminal state
yes so for the terminals I can
always put all lassigny its value
to the reward is observed in a two
so this is the special case when
I expected
upstream mines algorithms i'm going all of
following signed the value of my function
than the reward observed and that's
besides there that I'm going to study here
in my update because if I have a
mac on a single action because I
make a transition from the holy fathers
the terminal state or in fact I can
of actions to take so I'm going
use the ass value for action
danone which is equal to 1
if I do the math that's our ass
sarts at 3 which is zero point and
I'll be able to do it again
to interest and continue to do as much
of tests that I wish it according to a
stop criterion given either a number
fixed iterations or until
did my kuhn values ​​change not
a lot
or that in fact I could also
to watch is what my policy has stopped
to change in different states that
could be a stop hospital
possible but again we can
before the problem of one still the
dilemma in the exploration phase versus
exploitation so let's imagine I would have
could also take an action at 4 which
bring me back a state is king and that
it was ps3 house a reward
associates 2000
now since q2 s1 off cat is
equal to zero so his selection to 4 which
brought me one of 13.3 so at
initialization game reindeer initialized
the parry of qsr at 4 1 0
and since in my essay I put to
qds day to 3.9 while they were over
great than 0 but it's true that the
close thanks to each time she
would arrive at s1 she was never exploring
the action at 4 so never explore the state
is king so we also have here is a
problem with a potential problem of
lack of exploration your adaptation
to control this balance between
exploration and exploitation in the
ass learning it's worth it all
simply when I make the choice of
my support action that serves me
of exploration here so we see on my
value of 2 my function that rather than
fall of max
compared to actions on my function
that directly I wanted to go to
through my exploration function where I
consider, among other things, the number
of times that I have reached the express state
and that I did a potential action
to the premiums so that allows me
to artificially increase the
future reward hoped to associate with being
in the state and this price ends the action
off premiums by his father and
artificially increase it for
try a few times to do all
the different actions possible or
number of times I'm going to do this
action there is going to be associated their wheels to
threshold is only the handcuff in my
exploration function so if that's
so we can introduce the
concept of exploitation and exploration
which to control this balance there in the
panty box